معبر جوده عند الحدود بين السودان وجنوب
السودان
من هنا عبر اكثر من عشرين الف شخص من
الفارين من القتال
معظمهم من مواطني جنوب السودان ومعهم
رعايا من جنسيات اجنبيه لقد فروا من الحرب
واهوالها
عدم القروش هذه طلعنا ما في
هنا نمشي
احسن
الفارون من الحرب وصلوا الى مناطق امنه في
دوله جنوب السودان الا ان اوضاعهم صعبه
ففي هذا المطار بمنطقه فلوج علق الالاف في
انتظار ترحيلهم الى مناطق توجههم
عندنا ليله حرب واليوم هنا ميه ما في اكل
ما في شيء من السكن وفراسته ميال سكرين
عشان نقلب مميزه
منظمات اجاب لنا مباراه بسكويت
وديناه عشان يعملوا لها تحويل
كويس قالوا ما في سفر وما في تحويل دلوقتي
حاسه قاعدين في الشمس مويه بمشكله اكل بها
مشكله وانقطعنا نحن
السلطات والحكوميه ترحيل جميع العالقين
الى وجهتهم الاصليه والتخصيص مراكز لجوء
للاجانب ومعظمهم من اريتريا واثيوبيا
والصومال
موجودين في المحل كنا نشيله من هنا ما في
داعي
عشان يمشي يحسن عمليه
معقده والاوضاع الانسانيه صعبه والاعداد
ضخمه ويتعلق الامر بنحو ثلاثه ملايين شخص
بينهم الاف اللاجئين والمهاجرين ونحو
مليون ونصف مليون شخص من جنوب السودان من
طلاب وعمال يقيمون في السودان
وتتخوف السلطات في جنوب السودان من
استمرار الازمه فذلك يملي عليها تقديم
المعونه الانسانيه